Just to refresh your memory about micro
kernel based operating system structure, the idea is
micro kernel the micro kernel is providing a
small number of simple abstractions. Such as address
based and inter process communication and all
the system services that you normally expect from
an operating system. Such as the file system
Memory manager, CPU scheduling, and so on are
implemented as processes above microkernal. In
other words, these operating system services
run at the same privilege level as user-level applications. All of them
in their own individual address spaces. And only the microkernel runs at
a different level of privilege provided by the processor architecture. Since all
the operating system services are implemented as server's
processes on top of the microkernel, they may
have to cooperate with one another in order
to satisfy a particular user's request. And in
that case, they may have to talk to one another, and in order to do that,
they need IPC that is provided by the
microkernel in order to accomplish what is needed by
a particular system call emanating from an application.